there's a lot of folks that live life on
a cushy cloud of marshmallow and then
one day something goes wrong and I mean
that's why spoiled kids are so sad like
a spoiled young boy is one of the
saddest things ever a young boy that
becomes a man and can't take care of
himself and his dad has to keep on
rescuing him his dad has to keep on
bailing them out of situations and
giving them money I've met guys like
that and that is a crippling affliction
when they don't have the character
themselves to be able to get by in life
they constantly need someone to help
them and bail them out even as a grown
man I've met guys in their 40s that
still need help from their parents I'm
like man you're never gonna get it right
because somewhere along the line they
didn't face enough of the adversity to
realize that there's sometimes you just
got to get up and get you done there's
sometimes we have to pull yourself up
and you have to push forward even if you
want to stay in bed and if you don't do
that you just keep calling on your daddy
and your daddy keeps rescuing you you
never develop those tools you never
develop that ability to recognize what
you're doing wrong with your life
because you're you're soft you got a
cushiony you got a safety net a safety
net for your safety net if you had a 20
year old and he's just a doper or a
wakin bakes and doesn't get anything
done he's just always like hanging out
with his friends and playing video games
and he's just loser I wish there was a
way you could show someone like that
what your life would feel better and
richer if you had a goal you chased that
goal you would get this boost of
confidence you get this boost of
self-esteem maybe you're in a drawing
comic books maybe you're into nah but
making pottery or sculpture fine
whatever that is and pursue that instead
of doing nothing you just watch two
amazing clips from Joe Rogan take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]